sí
no volvería
[Música]
hello
hola cristina
tardes a todos bienvenidos a este
programa de capacitación de khan academy
estaba en el módulo número 2 de esta
capacitación
hola christine buenas tardes
hola buenas tardes a todos y todas
gracias por venir
soy christine de khan academy y vamos a
compartir un poco más de lo que estamos
haciendo para el regreso a clases y
también estamos en el módulo 2 de mi
programa de capacitación entonces
gracias por venir estamos muy
emocionadas porque tenemos mucho que
compartir con ustedes hay varios cambios
y varias cosas nuevas en la plataforma
de khan academy que realmente vienen a
añadir mucho valor a la plataforma y
obviamente hacer nuestro trabajo como
docente es mucho más fácil y sencillo mi
nombre es para ti garcía yo trabajo para
ti y trabajo en conjunto con con
christina para capacitar a los docentes
aqui en mexico en la herramienta de la
plataforma de canacar en
y bueno nuestro objetivo principalmente
es apoyarlos con el objetivo de que
puedan maximizar los resultados
académicos de todos sus alumnos tanto
las materias de matemáticas como de
ciencias yo lo personal y docente de
matemáticas y de ciencias por más o
menos diez años en el colegio americano
de la ciudad de mexico y bueno tengo
este muy claro no el tremendo reto que
tenemos como docentes y la tremenda
responsabilidad que tenemos no de educar
a nuestros alumnos y de enseñar a
nuestros alumnos lo que es lo que son
estas materias porque siempre existe
pueden ser los alumnos tienen siempre
muestra no de una reacción un poco
negativa hacia lo que es estas materias
de matemáticas y ciencias porque la
encuentran difícil porque les cuesta
trabajo pero yo creo de verdad que
muchas veces es porque no
no realmente no tienen las herramientas
para aprenderla de manera adecuada
entonces yo que khan academy nos puede
ofrecer esa herramienta que nos permita
realmente llegar a todos nuestros
alumnos entonces vamos a comenzar esta
es este es el enlace para la
presentación
los invito a que si tienen ustedes un
dispositivo a la mano entren a este
enlace y bueno pueden bajar la
presentación y quedarse la parada para
éste poder hacer referencia a ella en un
futuro
y aquellos que no tienen su dispositivo
a la mano bueno lo mejor sería tomarle
una foto a esta diapositiva para más
adelante cuando ya tengan su dispositivo
a la mano puedan bajarlo a su computador
entonces jeje punto jefe diagonal me
deje 5h todo con minúscula me voy a
esperar unos minutos para que todos
puedan bajarlo
ok vamos a seguir entonces como algunos
de ustedes ya saben porque sé que
algunos de ustedes ya utilizan la
plataforma ya ya lo han utilizado
previamente en años anteriores etcétera
quizá para algunos de ustedes esto es
nuevo no tienen ni siquiera una cuenta
en khan academy no se preocupen
rápidamente les vamos a decir cómo crear
su cuenta y cómo comenzar a utilizar
esta esta herramienta entonces
la misión de khan academy es ofrecer una
educación de primer nivel para cualquier
persona en cualquier lugar y esta parte
es muy importante porque la plataforma
de khan academy está disponible para
cualquier estudiante de la republica
mexicana que se encuentre realmente en
cualquier lugar y además esta plataforma
está accesible las 24 horas del día
entonces pueden acceder a ella en
cualquier momento
este la agenda para el día de hoy vamos
a comenzar con campeonato vamos a
explicarles que es de qué se trata
cuando comienza etcétera el siguiente
tema va a ser cómo poder crear un plan
para motivar y reconocer los logros de
nuestros alumnos durante este reto la
tercera va a ser lo que debo hacer para
que pueda ser reconocido como nuestro
campeón cómo podemos entrenar a otros
cómo podemos crear nuevas clases y
eliminar clases viejas cómo podemos
asignar tareas aquí tenemos un gran
cambio en la plataforma ese cambio
digamos la forma de asignar no tanto la
forma pero la manera en que vemos las
tareas que hemos asignado la verdad es
que está muy bien diseñada está no está
el nuevo cambio porque nos permite a
nosotros como docentes tener mucha más
facilidad de acceder a las
calificaciones ya los reportes de
nuestros alumnos
y también vamos a ver cuáles son estas
nuevas características y vamos a hablar
un poco de lo que es mentalidad de
crecimiento que estoy segura que les va
a encantar es también algo nuevo que
está promoviendo khan academy que
obviamente es para el beneficio de
nuestros alumnos eso les vamos a
platicar un poquito más durante la
presentación
algunos están teniendo problemas con la
presentación tengan cuidado con
mayúsculas minúsculas todas en este caso
son minúsculas
pueden abrirla y ya más adelante bajarla
a su computadora
bueno vamos ahorita vamos a ver la
presentación a través de el webinar y ya
más adelante reviso porque no están
pudiendo algunos entrar pero por ahora
vamos a concentrarnos en esta que no de
lo que es la pantalla pero es importante
que tengan el enlace para en un futuro
bajarla yo ahorita veo que el por qué
algunos no están pudiendo bajar bueno
vamos a comenzar con que es campeonato y
cuándo comienza que lo que tenemos que
hacer para participar
entonces el campeonato de canacar de mí
es un programa gratuito de 10 tiene una
duración de 10
semanas para impulsar el aprendizaje del
regreso a clases este programa fue
creado para el inicio de clases con el
objetivo de motivar a nuestros alumnos
de enganchar a los alumnos que realmente
plantear es otro panorama no con
respecto a la manera de aprender
matemáticas y ciencias no en este
programa vamos a combinar no solamente
actividades ejercicios artículos vídeos
etcétera de la plataforma pero también
vamos a estar utilizando y enviando a
nuestros alumnos actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento con el
objetivo de que la mente la mente de
nuestros alumnos se vaya haciendo más
fuerte y también digamos vayan madurando
no con respecto a su edad de las
actividades que van a ir desarrollando
cuál es el objetivo básicamente que el
alumno vaya ganando confianza que el
alumno vaya aumentando en su motivación
su seguridad dentro de la materia
ok
a ver voy a ver lo de la presentación
porque algunos no están pudiendo entrar
ahora ahora funciona en la liga y ellos
pueden ingresar y son a la línea en asia
art
sí porque está compartida para
cualquiera con el vínculo puede ver
entonces
esta está compartida de esta manera
entonces algo está pasando que algunos
no pueden ya pero ok vamos a seguir sea
cuando comienza campeonato las
inscripciones se abrieron ayer desde ya
hay ayer ustedes pueden ya registrarse
para participar en campeonato el reto
comienza sin embargo hasta el 10 de
septiembre y termina el 16 de noviembre
cualquier estudiante de la república
mexicana de primaria a bachillerato
puede participar y el objetivo como les
comentaba hace unos minutos
está hecho bueno este programa está
planeado y está pensado para motivar a
los estudiantes en el regreso a clase de
manera que nosotros como docentes
podamos realmente añadir más valor a
nuestras clases no yo creo que el
regreso a clases es siempre pesado no
tanto para los alumnos como para los
maestros y bueno campeonato es un
programa que viene la verdad es que
añadir como favor a nuestra clase como
que podemos hacer algo diferente en el
inicio de clases y de manera que
realmente el alumno pueda sentirse como
formando parte de algo no de un proyecto
en común con sus compañeros etcétera se
adapta fácilmente a todo tipo de aula a
los diferentes horarios ya los
diferentes ambientes escolares
ok cuáles son los principios del
campeonato no primero como les decía el
objetivo es inspirar confianza motivar
el aprendizaje significativo a nuestros
alumnos de manera que todos puedan
aprender yo creo que una parte
importante en estas materias es
personalizar el aprendizaje y realmente
digo yo yo soy docente y sé lo difícil
que es eso no porque a veces tenemos
pues muchísimos alumnos sino ser
verdaderamente imposible personalizar el
aprendizaje no y adaptarnos a las
necesidades de cada uno de nuestros
alumnos sino sin embargo esta plataforma
nos permite hacerlo nos permite
realmente adaptar y trabajar con las
necesidades específicas de cada uno de
nuestros alumnos promoviendo también
esta mentalidad de crecimiento no por
otro lado
este programa también empodera a los
alumnos 2 para nosotros el utiliza este
programa además de que nos va a permitir
hacer una conexión que es mucho más
padre mucho más intensa con nuestros
alumnos desde el principio de clases y
sabemos todos que es muy importante
crear ese vínculo con los alumnos no
crear ese enlace con ellos para para que
mejore la comunicación a través del año
no a lo largo del año entonces nos
permite también implementar una variedad
de lotes de actividades dentro del salón
de clases no hacer algo diferente para
nuestros alumnos siempre va a ser
motivante a nadie y yo creo que también
aquí la parte que a mí me más me encanta
es que como docentes tenemos una
herramienta que nos facilita el trabajo
como les comentaba nos permite
diferenciar de una manera más eficiente
y más fácil nos permite acceder a
reportes que son muy significativos en
nuestra práctica
y podemos además motivar a la vez a
nuestros alumnos y la verdad es que
bueno yo porque todos los profesores
somos héroes yo realmente respeto y
admiro la labor de todos los docentes
porque como les comentaba en un
principio tenemos una gran
responsabilidad y yo sé que le ponemos
mucho amor a nuestro trabajo no entonces
todos los profesores son héroes y yo
creo que esta herramienta viene a
hacernos ese trabajo tan importante
mucho más fácil y bueno como les
comentaba esta plataforma y este
programa está accesible para todos los
alumnos de la república mexicana es un
programa muy fácil de entender y la
verdad es que es muy fácil de seguir es
divertido y va celebrando el éxito no
solamente individual pero como grupo no
entonces se han creado se crearon
premios digitales especialmente para
este programa que los alumnos van
recibiendo a medida que van al kassar
alcanzando sus objetivos y sus robos
entonces cómo puedo participar como
profesor y aquí viene la parte más
importante los profesores lo primero que
hacen es agregan sus clases en canosa en
cada academia ustedes van a crear sus
clases y en el momento en que ustedes se
registran para participar en campeonato
automáticamente todas las clases que
ustedes tienen creadas automáticamente
van aa participar en campeonato el único
requisito es que las clases tengan diez
o más alumnos clases que tengan menos de
diez alumnos no pueden participar
entonces ustedes van a crear sus clases
se van a registrar en campeonato y
automáticamente todas sus clases creadas
van a participar ya en el reto de
campeonato
ok qué es lo que tenemos que hacer como
profesores nuestra labor como profesores
durante estas 10 semanas que dura este
programa es
asignar tres recursos a la semana mínimo
tres recursos semanales a cada uno de
nuestros alumnos esto quiere decir que
si por ejemplo nosotros tenemos un grupo
de 20 alumnos y vamos a asignar tres
recursos a cada uno de ellos en total
tenemos 60 recursos que todos los
alumnos tienen que contestar para que
realmente ganen el 100% de los puntos y
puedan ir logrando sus objetivos porque
está hecho de esta manera porque lo que
queremos es motivar a todos los alumnos
bien sabemos nosotros como docentes que
siempre tenemos alumnos que son muy
responsables que participan en todo que
todo lo entregan que todo lo terminar a
tiempo pero también tenemos alumnos que
se niegan a hacerlo no o que no
participan lo que les cuesta no entonces
sin embargo al hacerlo nosotros de esta
manera exigiendo la participación del
100% de nuestros alumnos vamos un
poquito a motivar a esos alumnos que
normalmente no participan a que hagan
también su trabajo no ya que hagan sus
ejercicios
porque si no de otra manera la clase no
cumple con sus objetivos o con no logra
el 100% y por ende los premios digitales
no entonces es muy importante esto
asignar tres recursos a cada uno de
nuestros alumnos por semana lo cual la
verdad es muy básico terminamos
asignando hasta más
acuérdense que en cada academia no
solamente tenemos vídeos en can academy
podemos asignar artículos podemos
asignar ejercicios a la vez que vídeos y
el profesor también va recibiendo
información de cuál es el avance de su
clase dentro del campeonato no hay un
tablero para ver el progreso que es muy
divertido se los voy a mostrar ahorita
como funciona entonces ese es
básicamente la labor del docente
muchos se preguntan ok si el programa
comienza el 10 de septiembre puedo
agregar clases una vez comenzado el
programa y la respuesta es sí yo puedo
agregar nuevas clases y sumar nuevas
clases a campeonato en cualquier momento
del reto entonces no es necesario no
comenzar antes del 10 sep tiene 10 de
septiembre pueden también sumar clases
más adelante ahora qué puedo hacer como
alumno para participar todos los
estudiantes deben completar los
ejercicios que el docente o que su
maestro le les asigna por semana de
manera que puedan ir ganando los puntos
necesarios no también tienen que
realizar las actividades de actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento
para que también vayan sumando puntos y
puedan tener acceso a estos premios y
medallas digitalizadas no que son de
edición limitada como les digo
especialmente creadas para este programa
la clase entera va a poder ver su
progreso a través de un tablet o que va
marcando momentos claves y metas
alcanzadas
una vez que bueno la clase logra sus
objetivos van a recibir premios
digitales etcétera y las escuelas que
alcancen más metas
recibirán un paquete sorpresa por parte
de can a cadena
ros como me pregunta como motivo a mis
alumnos de canacar a mí eso lo vamos a
ver dentro de la presentación un poquito
más adelante
ok entonces cuáles son estos premios
nosotros para celebrar el esfuerzo tanto
de profesores como de alumnos
khan academy ha creado medallas y
premios virtuales hechos especialmente
para este programa y también tres
premios especiales para los profesores
que participen con más de tres clases no
entonces aquí se va a reconocer el
esfuerzo tanto de docentes como de los
alumnos lo que es una parte muy
importante yo creo que el reconocimiento
y la motivación son parte fundamental de
este programa entonces cómo funciona
campeonato yo lo primero que yo voy a
hacer en caso de que yo no tenga una
cuenta con khan academy es crear una
cuenta en caracas
el siguiente paso es abrir mis clases y
ahorita vamos a ver cómo y comenzar a
asignar recuerden que a partir del 10 de
septiembre comienza ya el campeonato
entonces a partir de esa fecha empiezo a
asignar un mínimo de 3 actividades a mis
alumnos cada semana de manera que los
alumnos vayan realizando estas
actividades y también las actividades
actividades para fortalecer la mente los
estudiantes van a ir completando estos
ejercicios y que van a estar en cierta
manera personalizados no a sus
necesidades a los temas que están viendo
en clase etcétera y el objetivo es ir
desarrollando mentes más fuertes no
todas estas actividades van a ayudar a
que los alumnos no solamente entiendan
los conceptos lo que estamos
transmitiendo y los entiendan de una
mejor manera sino también que puedan ir
desarrollando estrategias de aprendizaje
y una mentalidad más fuerte y finalmente
vamos a celebrar el el avance y los
logros de nuestros alumnos no a través
de como les comenté diversos premios a
los que van a tener acceso entonces este
es más o menos el tablero de no del para
ver el progreso entonces en este tablero
una vez que ustedes se registran con sus
clases se registran para participar en
campeonato
automáticamente van a tener acceso a
este
pero que va a medir el progreso de la
clase entonces aquí ellos van alcanzando
diferentes niveles son hasta siete
niveles
entonces el objetivo es alcanzar el 100%
en cada nivel y ya lo alcanzamos a
medida que los alumnos que todos
nuestros alumnos completan sus
actividades ese es el objetivo no
entonces ahí viene pues nuestra labor
maestros no nuestra labor de motivar a
todos para que todos participen al 100%
entonces en el tablero del progreso
vamos a ver y viendo cuál es el progreso
logrado y el nivel logrado a través del
programa y los alumnos también van a
poder ir también monitoreando cuál es su
progreso y esto es algo como muy
emocionante para ellos quiero compartir
con ustedes este vídeo
de eeuu de alumnos de eeuu eso los voy a
poner hay perdón
bueno
los hombres dudamos
bueno como podrán ver realmente los
alumnos se emocionan no yo creo que esta
parte bueno a mí me encanta porque es
comenzar el año con algo diferente con
algo nuevo hacer que nuestros alumnos se
sientan que están formando parte de algo
no participando en algo no que forma que
pertenecen algo yo creo que este sentido
de pertenencia es muy importante y más
al principio de año no para claramente
crear un ambiente en clase muy favorable
para el aprendizaje porque finalmente
este trabajo colaborativo etcétera es
muy positivo para nuestros alumnos
entonces es una manera excelente de
comenzar el año de motivarlos de
emocionar los de hacer equipo recuerden
que el campeonato es para niños desde
primaria hasta bachillerato no estos
para cualquier nivel escolar y recuerden
únicamente que el requisito es que sus
clases tengan de 10 a más alumnos
ok acá tenemos a otro se lo quiero
compartir
estos son alumnos de brasil
celebrando que alcanzaron su objetivo
[Aplausos]
aquí nos muestran que llegaron al 6 al
nivel 6 con el 100% no entonces al
obtener el 100% del nivel 6 van
recibiendo ahí van teniendo acceso a
diferentes premios digitales y
reconocimientos
ok vamos a continuar
ok cuáles son estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento entonces vamos
a hablar sobre estas actividades esto es
algo nuevo en khan academy que es muy
importante porque realmente vamos a el
objetivo es que los alumnos conozcan la
manera en que aprenden muchos de
nuestros alumnos no saben bien cuáles
son las mejores estrategias que ellos
deben seguir para aprender entonces es
realmente de mucho valor el que al
principio del año el alumno se pueda
conocer y pueda realmente desarrollar
una mente más fuerte no que que conozca
la verdad sobre su cerebro cómo puede él
aprender de una manera mejor no igual
vos escucharás porque digo en estas dos
materias nuestros alumnos están muy
acostumbrados al fracaso
y se enfrentan mucho a la frustración y
desgraciadamente son factores que
afectan grandemente su desempeño y
sabemos señores que tenemos alumnos que
con tal de no enfrentarse a las
matemáticas son las ciencias
tratan de evitar cualquier carrera lo
que tenga que ver con matemáticas y
ciencias no necesitamos realmente
fomentar a nuestros jóvenes en méxico no
este amor o este gusto por las
matemáticas y las ciencias porque
necesitamos más científicos y más
matemáticas y más ingenieros en este
país no entonces estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento realmente
enseñan al alumno a lidiar con la
frustración qué pasa si yo tengo comete
un error qué pasa si yo no puedo hacer
algo me voy a dar por vencido o va a ser
un factor para que yo me esfuerce más
para que yo logre tener éxito no
entonces esto es lo que nosotros vamos a
desarrollar no lo que es la resiliencia
lo que es las estrategias para aprender
mejor dentro de estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento no de manera
que puedan ellos superar mejor la
frustración y siempre tener como mira
adelante no la mira hacia adelante y no
no detenerse en ésta
la desmotivación esta frustración en
esta angustia de no poder
entonces aquí tenemos un testimonio de
un maestro del conalep que me encanta
porque dice el lobo más significativo es
que los estudiantes tienen ahora más
interés por aprender matemáticas lo
hacen ahora de una manera significativa
orientada a su vida real
gracias maribel por este testimonio yo
estoy totalmente de acuerdo con lo que
dice esta maestra porque bueno a través
de mis años de docencia que yo llevo
utilizando esta plataforma muchos años
en el salón de clases y les puedo contar
bueno muchísimas historias de hoy y en
muchísimos casos en que he visto como
mis alumnos de la desmotivación y de la
frustración en realmente pasado a
tenerle gusto a la materia y de repente
sentir que pueden no porque la
plataforma se va adaptando a la uci a
las capacidades de cada uno de nuestros
alumnos y es aquí donde podemos
personalizar el aprendizaje ellos van a
su propio ritmo no van teniendo acceso a
diferentes
recursos que les ayudan a comprender
mejor y entonces el alumno va
sintiéndose más seguro va agarrando
confianza va sintiéndose más a sus
anchas y obviamente agarrando un poquito
más de cariño a la materia no y se dan
cuenta que no es tanto el que el que no
puedan o el que no entiendan es todo
actitud no qué actitud tenemos ante las
cosas que resultan difíciles para
nosotros
bueno el campeonato comienza el 10 de
septiembre como les comenté hace unos
minutos las el registro ya está abierto
desde ayer ya podemos inscribirnos al
campeonato desde ayer sin embargo el
campeonato oficialmente comienza el 10
de septiembre recuerden que es gratuito
para las paradas etcétera y realmente le
van a agregar un enorme valor a su clase
al comenzar con este programa no que va
a ser muy motivador
pues vamos a ver cómo puedo motivar y
reconocer el logro de mis alumnos
durante este programa entonces yo creo
que es muy importante ya todos nos gusta
no ser reconocidos a todos nos gusta que
valoren nuestro trabajo valoren nuestro
esfuerzo reconozcan nuestros logros es
parte vital y no solamente digo dentro
de la escuela sino en general en nuestra
vida diaria no y también no solamente en
matemáticas o ciencias sino también en
todas nuestras materias en todas
nuestras actividades entonces es muy
importante que como docentes tengamos un
plan de acción y creemos un plan de
acción para motivar y para reconocer el
logro de nuestros alumnos no cuál sería
su plan para seguir el progreso de los
alumnos cómo lo van a medir cómodos ahí
en la plataforma tenemos varios reportes
que nos van diciendo cómo van mejorando
en donde están esté padeciendo no que lo
que les está costando trabajo
en cuanto digamos como no como los
podemos ayudar etcétera yo creo que esto
depende de cada maestro a todos nosotros
tenemos diferentes personalidades ahora
también es importante conocer a nuestros
alumnos y yo sé que bueno ahorita van a
estar regresando a clases es difícil que
conozcan a sus alumnos en la primera en
una semana no en las primeras semanas de
clase pero bueno al final yo creo que
sabemos que a todos los alumnos
generalmente les gusta lo mismo no
simplemente un pequeño reconocimiento y
la verdad aquí pueden entrar diferentes
formas no yo recuerdo
lo que yo hacía les puedo contar lo que
yo hacía en la escuela pero para poder
antes no reconocer el logro yo creo que
es muy importante tener objetivos claros
como maestros tenemos que plantearle a
nuestros alumnos cuáles son nuestros
objetivos en campeonato es muy fácil es
lograr el 100% en cada uno de los siete
niveles ese es el objetivo no a través
de este objetivo podemos ir motivando
los para que lo alcancen pero una vez
que termine el programa y la plataforma
comience su uso habitual es siempre es
importante siempre tener un plan para
motivar a nuestros alumnos no y para eso
es primero objetivo es claro es que
quiero que logre yo cuando era docente
lo que hacía esa ponía diferentes
objetivos a lo largo del año y cuando
llegabas a cierto momento digamos
revisaba quienes habían alcanzado el
objetivo y aquellos que los habían
alcanzado les llevaba un lápiz no sé
simpático o a veces les llevaba a un
fin en una ocasión compré una pizza y
invite a los niños que habían logrado
sus objetivos a comer pizza durante el
recreo esto ya va variando como les digo
según sus posibilidades según sus
personalidades etcétera no un aplauso un
diploma un póster no me dentro del salón
de clases
cualquiera que sea una tarjetita no
cualquiera que sea la forma yo creo que
eso va a motivar mucho a los alumnos no
y también va a hacer que los alumnos que
no están teniendo tan buen desempeño se
esfuercen un poco maestro entonces
también cómo vamos a celebrar sus logros
no que qué actividades vamos a hacer qué
podemos hacer dentro de clase dentro de
la escuela no también este
no solamente a nivel salón de clase sino
a nivel plantel qué puedo hacer para
celebrar a todos mis alumnos no cómo voy
a evaluar también el desempeño y el
esfuerzo de mis alumnos en khan academy
ya que esta parte también depende de
cada plantel no yo creo que sí es
importante asignar un porcentaje de la
calificación total del alumno a khan
academy no tan academy hoy día nos
permite tener también una calificación
etcétera en total un porcentaje ya sea
10% o 15% lo que sea lo que no ustedes
decidan pero que sí se les reconozca ese
esfuerzo al alumno dentro de su trabajo
en la plataforma no para que se
esfuercen mejor
ok que debo hacer yo como maestro para
ser reconocido como un maestro campeón
pero bueno antes de entrar esta parte el
christina creo que tenemos varias
preguntas
no sé si quieras que las conteste más de
una vez juntas de la inscripción al
campeonato por ejemplo
si hay una clase con el contenido que
viene por tipo esto cuenta
a veces vuelvo a este
y digo les vuelvo a decir esta
información a reforzar esta información
ustedes todas las clases que ya tienen
creadas al registrarse la línea escriben
este interinato todas sus clases ya
creadas van a participar en campeonato
es por eso que es importantísimo que si
tienen clases ya muertas que fueron de
años previos las eliminan y ahorita les
voy a enseñar cómo se elimina sí es muy
importante que antes de que se inscriban
eliminen todas las clases que ya no
están usando de años anteriores que ya
están muertas digamos no entonces lo el
primer paso es eliminar clases que ya no
estoy usando y lo segundo es crear mis
nuevas clases y si todavía estoy sola
las clases las dejo abiertas y el
tercero ya es inscribirme en el
campeonato de ahí automáticamente todas
las clases que yo tengo creadas van a
participar en campeonato
aquí tengo una pregunta
ya abrí las clases para los grupos de
este semestre mari carmen perfecto en el
momento que te inscribas a campeonato
automáticamente estas clases van a
participar en este programa
francisca rubio y ya con estas clases y
en cuanto ingresen los alumnos ya
estaremos participando recuerden que una
vez creadas sus clases ya que hayan
invitado a sus alumnos un mínimo de 10
se inscriben y automáticamente al
inscribirse en campeonato ya están
participando
y qué más tengo aquí
[Música]
yo podré socorro yo podré crear mis
clases hasta después del 20 de agosto
que es cuando comienzan las clases
perfecto ningún problema recuerden que
el campeonato como tal comienza hasta el
10 de septiembre
pero además si quieren agregar una clase
una vez comenzado campeonato lo pueden
hacer
francisca aún no he borrado las del
semestre pasado te recomiendo francisco
francisca perdón que las borres antes de
inscribirte para que no queden
automáticamente sumadas a campeonato
esas clases que ya no estás dando no
y agregué clases entre la semana pasada
y esta se toman en cuenta diana
nuevamente en el momento que tú te
inscribas en campeonato esas clases que
creaste la semana pasada y esta quedan
automáticamente participando
creo que hasta ahorita son todas las
preguntas que tenemos entonces vamos a
continuar con qué debo hacer para que me
reconozcan como un maestro campeón
entonces lo primero es participar dentro
de esta capacitación
esta capacitación consta de tres módulos
en el módulo uno tuvo lugar el 1º de
agosto
bueno en agosto está ya se realizó sin
embargo vamos a compartir con ustedes el
enlace de este webinar para que si no
asistieron si no estuvieron presentes
pues lo puedan ver no puedan acceder al
vídeo de youtube y puedan ver el módulo
1 en donde vimos cuáles son los pasos en
khan academy vimos lineamientos
conocimos un poquito la plataforma más a
fondo vimos un poco las nuevas
características de la plataforma que lo
vamos a ver también hoy hay muchas cosas
nuevas y hablamos un poco de mentalidad
de crecimiento que también vamos a
hablar hoy de eso en este módulo 2
estamos hablando sobre campeonato y como
le dije vamos a hablar de cómo motivar a
los alumnos reconocer sus logros cómo
abrir a clases cómo borrar clases
asignar tareas utilizando las nuevas
características de la plataforma y vamos
a hablar también de mentalidad de
crecimiento el módulo 3 tendrá lugar más
adelante por octubre y noviembre en
donde estaremos hablando de cómo crear
un plan no para motivar a nuestros
alumnos creando ceremonias no a la mejor
dentro del plantel etcétera para que
responde conozcan los logros y esfuerzos
de nuestros alumnos y también hablaremos
del reconocimiento a los docentes
yo creo que aquí lo más importante es
para para hacer un campeón para ser un
maestro campeón que como les digo yo yo
creo que todos somos campeones no todos
los que estamos en docencia y en
educación son campeones pero hay que
motivar a los alumnos no yo creo que
aquí es donde entra nuestra labor más
importante y nuestro reto como docente
de nuestro reto más importante no a
veces es muy fácil motivar algunos
alumnos aquí el reto es motivar a todos
no a todos nuestros alumnos a los que
les gustan matemáticas a los que no no
entonces los queremos también aquí a que
compartan sus ideas sus experiencias con
nosotros todas las experiencias que
ustedes tienen dentro del salón de
clases para nosotros son valiosísimas
estos de verdad los queremos invitar a
que nos escriban les voy a proporcionar
un correo más adelante donde nos pueden
compartir sus experiencias sus ideas
etcétera a lo mejor cuando están sus
alumnos viendo el tablero de progreso
grabar un vídeo de sus alumnos
de cómo están percibiendo la información
de cómo están si los ven motivados cómo
están participando en nuestro programa y
todos estos vídeos que ustedes vayan
creando que ustedes vayan grabando y nos
envíen bueno para nosotros van a ser muy
valiosos porque es una manera de
realmente demostrarlo en en méjico y
demostrar lo que realmente nuestros
alumnos están siendo motivados e
impactados de una manera positiva por
esta plataforma
entonces vamos a entrar de lleno a como
elimino clases viejas y como creo nuevas
clases no
entonces antes que nada vamos a entrar
en ese punto khan academy punto org
aquellos que tienen sus platas perdón
sus dispositivos los invito a que entren
a este enlace este punto khan academy
punto org aquí los vamos a tener acceso
a la plataforma en español y aquí la
gran noticia maestros la gran maravilla
de esta plataforma es que está alineada
a la sep entonces nosotros al asignar
primero de secundaria segundo de
secundaria con un curso etcétera sabemos
que estamos realmente cubriendo todas
nuestras necesidades que realmente
estamos adaptándonos al plan que tenemos
que cubrir por parte de la cepa entonces
eso es algo invaluable no es no sé es de
mucha ayuda porque realmente podemos
recargar los nuevos o podemos utilizar
esta plataforma con mucha tranquilidad
claudia caballero pregunta si se pueden
ir agregando alumnos poco a poco o todos
al mismo tiempo
lo ideal es todos al mismo tiempo sin
embargo sabemos que hay alumnos que se
pueden añadir al salón de clases más
adelante y podemos agregar los sin
ningún problema no sin ningún problema
pero digo lo ideal y ahorita vamos a ver
cómo hacerlo es añadir a la mayoría de
nuestros alumnos
no en un momento
ok entonces para aquellos que no tienen
una cuenta en khan academy la mayoría de
ustedes ya lo tienen pero aquellos que
no les voy a pedir que entren nuevamente
a ese punto khan academy punto org y van
a hacer clic en maestros inicien aquí no
han paga a ser clic en la parte que dice
maestros inicien aquí y automáticamente
se les va a abrir una segunda ventana
que indica del número dos y tenemos tres
diferentes maneras de registrarnos una
es a través de nuestra cuenta de google+
otra es a través de facebook o la
tercera sería a través de nuestro correo
electrónico yo siempre les recomiendo
que lo hagan a través de su correo
electrónico porque porque de repente
facebook seremos nuestra cuenta o lo que
sea y ya perdimos toda nuestra
información y ya perdimos nuestras
clases etcétera entonces si les sugiero
que lo hagan a través del correo
electrónico y este correo electrónico
con el que se van a registrar es el
mismo correo que van a utilizar
en todas las fórmulas formularios que
tengan que completar de khan academy
etcétera para que siempre le llegue
información tanto de su progreso o de
nuevas noticias etcétera por parte de
can a caer en él una vez que hagamos
clic en registrarme con mi correo
electrónico se abre una tercera ventana
en donde yo tengo que poner el correo
electrónico mi nombre mi apellido y
crear una contraseña traten de utilizar
este ocho diferentes caracteres
numerosos símbolos letras etcétera pero
también es importante que apunten ese
esa contraseña en algún lugar donde se
acuerde no porque luego también se nos
olviden perdemos todo nuestro trabajo y
nuestras clases etcétera
de khan academy entonces si tengan esto
muy presente entonces sigan estos tres
sencillos pasos y automáticamente van a
crear su cuenta una vez que completan su
correo electrónico su nombre su apellido
y crean su contraseña automáticamente
entran a la plataforma y van a entrar a
esta parte ahorita van a entrar a la
parte de ya comenzar a crear sus
primeras clases para esta parte me voy a
salir de la presentación y voy a entrar
a la plataforma de lleno entonces voy a
entrar aquí voy a hacer un cambio y esta
viene siendo la plataforma
como les dije ustedes sigan los pasos si
es que no tienen todavía una cuenta aquí
van a hacer clic en maestros e inician
aquí y van a seguir los pasos si ustedes
ya tienen una cuenta con khan academy lo
único que tienen que hacer es iniciar
sesión entonces yo voy a ingresar aquí
min
correo
voy a encontrar entrar mi contraseña
y automáticamente hago clic en iniciar
sesión e
a lo que es la página principal de mi
cuenta de khan academy entonces esta es
la página principal de mi cuenta
una vez que ustedes creen su cuenta van
a entrar aquí obvio los que acaban de
crear su cuenta aquí no van a tener nada
porque no tienen ninguna clase creada yo
estas clases son las que tengo creadas
por eso aparecen ahí entonces fíjense
aquí ya está el banner para escribirnos
al campeonato es así de sencillo señores
ustedes van a entrar a la plataforma y
automáticamente cuando ustedes tengan
sus clases creadas y estén listos
automáticamente van a hacer clic a quien
inscríbete al campeonato no van a seguir
los pasos y automáticamente van a
ingresar todas las clases que ustedes
hayan creado nuevamente repito si
quieren agregar clases después del 10 de
septiembre que inicie el campeonato lo
pueden hacer
si quieren agregar alumnos a una de sus
clases una vez que haya empezado
campeonato también lo pueden hacer ok
ok aquí en esta parte tenemos fíjese
aquí del lado derecho en la parte
inferior dice agregar una clase si en
letras azules entonces vamos a ver los
pasos para agregar una clase lo que yo
voy a hacer es hacer clic en agregar una
clase no entonces se abre esta ventana y
me dice ok como se va a llamar tu clase
entonces yo voy a poner ok de modo vamos
a poner demo
módulo
módulo 2
khan academy ok entonces le pongo nombre
a mi clase que puede ser primero de
secundaria periodo tres no tercero de
secundaria
no sé no sé etcétera una vez listo le
voy a dar clic en siguiente y aquí viene
la parte en donde yo voy a asignar un
curso a mi clase este curso de que es
aquí fíjense cómo lo tengo clasificado
aquí me aparece por matemáticas puedo
asignarlo ya sea real yebra ya sea
álgebra geometría básica etcétera o
puedo asignarlo por grado si yo estoy
dando primero secundaria segundo y
secundaria 1º bachillerato etcétera o
biología química física o ingeniería
eléctrica entonces vamos a suponer que
mi clase es de segundo de secundaria
recuerden también que es muy importante
que esto lo sepan que yo puedo asignar
más de un curso yo puedo decir ok voy a
enseñar primero y segundo en este curso
porque puede darse el caso que yo les
voy a dar primero el material de primero
de secundaria pero al final voy a
empezar a meter ciertos temas de segundo
de secundaria y recuerden también que
esto yo lo puedo editar una vez creada
mi clase en configuración
yo puedo editar también este curso puedo
agregar o puedo quitar etcétera eso no
es problema nos vamos a dejarlo como
primero de secundaria entonces una vez
que asignó el curso del siguiente
y comienza ya el tercer paso que es
agregar a mis alumnos
entonces yo tengo tres diferentes
maneras de agregar lo puede importar lo
si estoy utilizando google classroom
puedo importarlo desde google classroom
puedo enviar una invitación por correo
electrónico en este caso lo que necesito
por los correos electrónicos de mis
alumnos entonces a él para esto a lo
mejor les mandaría un formulario para
que me puedes recolectar todos los
correos electrónicos no de manera que
pueda tener acceso a todos
o bien aquí voy a poner por ejemplo me
voy a invitar a mí misma
ok y también otra manera de hacerlo pues
puede ser a través de un código
cada vez que yo creo una clase
automáticamente se crea un código
especial para esa clase yo siempre les
voy a sugerir que utilicen este método
la verdad es el leer más rápido y el más
efectivo porque puedo aprovechar el
hecho de que de tener a todos mis
alumnos juntos en el salón de clase y
les voy a pedir que vayan a cada academy
punto org diagonal join sí y una vez que
los alumnos entran en esta sección de
únete a una clase aquí ellos van a
ustedes pueden copiar este código en el
pizarrón así en letras bien grandes les
van a pedir que entren a khan academy
punto org diagonal join y en esta parte
que dice únete a una clase los alumnos
van a pegar ahí o van a escribir ahí el
código que ustedes les den y le ponen
únete a la clase automáticamente
unidos a la clase dice has ingresado con
éxito a la clase entonces la manera más
rápido más rápida y más efectiva de
agregar a sus alumnos porque les digo ya
lo he comentado antes y porque si me ha
pasado que un mes después estoy
persiguiendo mis alumnos que les mande
el correo y rogándole es que me acepten
y mismo puede volver a enviar porque ya
lo perdí porque me lo encuentro etcétera
entonces ahorres de problemas y hágalo a
través del código no también pueden
hacer clic a quien imprimir estas
instrucciones éstas todavía las tenemos
en inglés no la hemos traducido pero
aquí pueden agregar el código de la
clase y compartirlo con sus alumnos no
si es que quieren hacerlo por por
escrito para que tengan
no las instrucciones de cómo inscribirse
en su clase pero lo pueden pegar en su
cuaderno etcétera
volvamos entonces entonces una vez que
yo ya invite a mis alumnos
automáticamente se activa este botón que
dice invitar a alumnos entonces invito a
mis alumnos y automáticamente una vez
que yo tengo mis alumnos inscritos se
abre esta tercera ventana que me dice ok
tu clase ya está creada ya ha sido
creada y ahora sí ya puedo encontrar
ejercicios vídeos artículos para mi
clase que es primero de secundaria y
aquí puedo decir ok explora el contenido
de primero de secundaria entonces si yo
hago clic aquí automáticamente me va a
abrir ya mi clase se digan aquí está el
nombre de la clase y qué curso es el que
estoy dándole a esta clase primero de
secundaria y siempre todas sus clases
van a tener el mismo menú de contenido
tareas avanza actividad lista y
configuración aquí en contenido yo voy a
tener el acceso a todos los conceptos lo
que se requiere que los alumnos aprendan
en primero de secundaria
quizás falte en algunos temas pero bueno
hay que enfocarnos a lo positivo khan
academy sigue y continúa trabajando
hasta la fecha en adaptarlo lo más
cercano posible a las necesidades de
méxico
definitivamente todavía hay mucho más
que hacer hay mucho que agregar hay
todavía mucho trabajo por hacer sin
embargo lo básico aquí está y de verdad
es que quizás no encontremos material
para un tema pero si vamos a encontrar
material para 6 más 2 enfoquémonos y
usemos esta plataforma para aquellos
aquellas unidades con las que si no
vamos a encontrar recursos dentro de la
plataforma entonces yo aquí ya puedo
decir ok de fracciones no sé a principio
del año las primeras semanas voy a
repasar fracciones desde aquí puedo
asignarlos y ahorita vamos a ver esa
parte de co2 asignó tareas y recursos a
mis alumnos entonces de modo regresar a
la presentación entonces cómo creó una
clase en khan academy
ya vimos los pasos que debo seguir
también están aquí en la presentación
para que no lo olviden
vamos a ver ahora cómo elimino una clase
en khan academy y esto como les
comentaba es muy importante muy
importante que lo hagan antes de
inscribirse en campeonato entonces como
eliminó la verdad es muy fácil muy
sencillo no nos toma ni siquiera un
minuto para esto recuerden que aquí si
yo hago clic en khan academy
automáticamente en mi caso me va a
llevar a mi página principal que yo
elegí que fuera mi página como tutor
recuerden que en can academy
yo puedo cambiar mi rol de tutor a mí a
mi rol de alumno yo puedo tener ambos
roles entonces yo aquí entro a lo que
son todas mis clases aquí tengo el menú
de todas las clases que yo he creado
como elimino de una clase es muy
sencillo voy a seleccionar la clase que
quiero limitar en este caso voy a
seleccionar esta que acabo de crear no
entonces me voy a la clase que quiero
eliminar le hago clic
y se abre la clase y yo aquí en
configuración fíjense aquí en este botón
de configurar perdón de configuración
hago clic y aquí tengo el nombre de la
clase aquí es donde les comentaba que yo
puedo cambiar el curso si lo quiero
cambiar o agregar un curso más pero aquí
también en la parte superior aquí del
lado derecho dice eliminar esta clase y
morosa con hacer clic es muy sencillo
hago clic mea me sale un mensaje de
confirmación
quieres cancelar esta clase le pongo ok
y automáticamente la clase queda
eliminada como verán un minuto el
estómago entonces si los invito a que
con tiempo eliminen esas clases para que
además pues no se confundan con sus
nuevas clases no entonces eliminen todas
las clases del pasado que yo que ya no
están utilizando que ya no van a
utilizar y ahora si den sea la tarea de
crear sus nuevas clases
preguntas hasta aquí christina
si tenemos algunas preguntas de
conectividad podrías explicar
como pueden ingresar a la liga de punto
y punto canacar mi punto hereje con
a esta liga de ese punto 0 punto cada
punto org es una liga para que los
alumnos no se puedan ingresar desde su
celular sin tener que utilizar datos no
entonces esta parte es vital es muy
importante porque pues en muchos casos
no tenemos internet en las en las
escuelas o estos 2
sin embargo se utilizan esta liga no
automáticamente pueden tener acceso a la
plataforma sin tener que usar
sus datos no se la puedes poner
christine en el chat porque yo no la
tengo aquí en la presentación entonces
el dinero
perdón
esta sala se las puedo compartir también
al final porque al final de la
presentación está también este enlace
entonces se los puedo enseñar pero es un
enlace que acceden desde su celular y a
los alumnos les permite entrar sin tener
que utilizar sus datos lo cual es
buenísima al final al es nuestro cuál es
cuál es este esa dirección a la que
tienen que ir para para poder hacer esto
cecilia cruz pregunta a mis alumnos
deben tener su cuenta y qué requisitos
están para crearla es muy sencillo crear
su cuenta como alumnos no necesita
ningún rector ningún requisito más que
tener su correo electrónico su nombre
etcétera y es muy fácil crearla no
también para ellos lo pueden hacer si no
lo tienen si no tienen una vuelta creada
porque no han utilizado cada academia
antes lo pueden hacer junto con ustedes
en el salón de clases antes de que
ustedes no de que se inscriban a su
clase lo primero sería ayudarlos a todos
a abrir su cuenta para después ya que se
sumen a sus clases
como un cambio de rol de tutor a alumno
es muy buena pregunta aquí arriba cuando
yo estoy dentro de de mi cuenta digamos
acá arriba tengo el logo de khan academy
y acá del lado derecho en la parte
superior tengo mi nombre o el nombre de
cada uno de ustedes al estar listo es
clic en el nombre se abre este menú aquí
tengo dos páginas de inicio del
aprendizaje y página de control de tutor
si yo hago clic en inicio del
aprendizaje quiere decir que yo soy
alumno yo voy a empezar a aprender aquí
entonces si yo hago clic aquí
automáticamente me va a llevar a mi rol
como alumno si esta soy yo como alumno
aquí al alumno le aparecen todas las
clases a las capas a las que pertenece
dentro de khan academy porque puede
pertenecer a una de biología puede
pertenecer a una de física puede
pertenecer estar tomando una de pre
álgebra y otra de no sé de sexto
semestre de bachillerato etcétera no
entonces pueden pertenecer a diferente
clases y aquí les van a aparecer todas
las tareas que tienen de las diferentes
clases a las que pertenecen aquí
aparecen sus tutores sus diferentes
tutores etcétera no entonces está en mi
página como alumno si vuelvo a hacer
clic en mi nombre y ahora me voy a a mi
página como tutor hago clic y
automáticamente me va a llevar a mi
página de maestro en dónde puedo
encontrar todas mis clases o bien
agregar una clase
ok entonces esta parte es importante muy
buena pregunta juan carlos torres
otra cosa que quiero decirles también
que yo creo que es importante saber
cuando yo estoy en mi cuenta digamos y
hago clic otra vez en mi nombre y se van
a configuración para que usted siempre
se vayan a su página como tutor cuando
hagan clic en el logo aquí en
configuración ustedes aquí abajo les va
a decir ok
tu página aquí van a ser en roles van a
hacer clic en los dos estudiantes y
maestro y aquí en qué página quieres que
aparezca o cuál quieres quizá tu página
principal no la de tutor o bien la de
estudiante yo voy a seleccionar la de
tutor y guarden los cambios para que
automáticamente cada vez que ustedes
hagan clic en el logo automáticamente la
plataforma los lleve a su página como
tutor
ok entonces ninguna duda sobre cómo
eliminar una clase en khan academy
verdad esto
ok vamos a vamos a continuar ahorita el
siguiente tema es cómo voy a asignar
tareas no cómo puedo recuerden que yo
tengo que dentro de campeonato tengo que
asignar tres recursos a todos mis
alumnos por semana mínimo tres recursos
por semana cómo voy a hacer esto
entonces nuevamente para esto voy a
regresar a la plataforma si voy a entrar
a una de las clases que ya tengo creadas
voy a entrar a ésta
ok y aquí vamos a ver cómo asigno
contenido a mis clases no entonces en
este caso en esta clase que yo tengo
creada se llama capacitación jj s y el
curso que yo estoy dando es de pre
algebra entonces al hacer clic en
contenido automáticamente voy a tener
acceso a todos los conceptos no a la
mayoría de los conceptos
que necesito o que necesitan mis alumnos
aprender en este curso entonces vamos a
suponer que yo veo que hay propiedades
aritméticas voy a hacer clic en
propiedades aritméticas que es lo que
estoy viendo la unidad que estoy viendo
en estas primeras semanas de clase
entonces voy a ver ok cómo puedo usar
valor posicional no y recuerden que yo
siempre tengo acceso a vídeos ejercicios
puede también por haber haber por ahí
algún artículo con lo como es en este
caso acá abajo etcétera no entonces yo
puedo decir que quiero
y asignar un vídeo porque recuerden que
tienen que ser tres recursos entonces
quiero ver encontrar el valor o
introducción no encontrar el valor
posicional voy a hacer clic en vista
previa y esto me va a permitir ver como
el alumno va a ver este recurso yo creo
que esta parte también es muy importante
para también ser nosotros empáticos no
con nuestros alumnos y saber bien cómo
están recibiendo ellos estos recursos
entonces aquí incluso puedo ver el valor
4.356 cuando me preguntan sobre el valor
posicional y mientras más ejercicios
hagan esto se volverá ok entonces si yo
estoy de acuerdo con el vídeo es algo
que bien clase etcétera entonces me voy
nuevamente a mi plataforma o sea a un
paso atrás digo que voy a seleccionar el
vídeo los que ya han utilizado los
vídeos de khan academy no me dejarán
mentir estos vídeos son de verdad
maestros es sencillos fáciles de
entender cortos y los sale alumnos
nuestros alumnos tienen acceso a estos
vídeos en cualquier momento son como un
tutor personalizado no de un tutor en
todo momento lo que les puedo decir o
dar una clave o ayudarlos a resolver
cierto ejercicio en el que están un poco
atorados y vamos a ver también este dice
bueno introducción al valor posicional
vista previa entonces en este caso son
ejercicios también quiero ver cómo el
alumno va a ver estos ejercicios y
fíjense en estos ejercicios a los
estudiantes se les van
a hacer siete preguntas de veinte aquí
en esto tengo veinte diferentes
preguntas sin embargo los alumnos
siempre reciben segmentos de siete
preguntas no los ejercicios constan de
siete o los recursos perdón constan de
siete ejercicios entonces cómo lo va a
ver el alumno el alumno va a percibir
estos ejercicios de esta manera no
entonces aquí va a tener y va ir
respondiendo puede utilizar una pista
puede ver un vídeo y son siete los
problemas que tienen que comprobar a
medida que va resolviendo uno se va
presentando el otro no va va entrando en
la siguiente pregunta entonces si yo
estoy de acuerdo cierro aquí y digo ok
me gusta este ejercicio voy a asignar
este ok y si me voy hasta acá abajo digo
bueno aquí tengo otros ejercicios y
escriben números naturales en notación
extendida nuevamente veo cuáles son
estos ejercicios van a recibir 7 de 15
diferentes opciones estoy de acuerdo
pero las preguntas digo tienen la
capacidad de resolver esto
y seleccionó también estos ejercicios
si se fijan en el momento en que yo hago
clic y seleccionó automáticamente se
enciende este botón de asignar y aquí me
está indicando ya que estoy asignando
tres recursos ok
todos yo hago clic en asignar recursos y
se me abre esta ventana y esta ventana
bueno que les puedo decir es mágica yo
puedo a desde aquí decir bueno quiero
que los alumnos trabajen en ejercicios
aleatorios de aquí si nos preocupa esta
cosa de que copian en la tarea de que se
pasen los resultados o de que uno
conteste la tarea del otro etcétera con
esto evitamos eso porque todos nuestros
alumnos van a recibir ejercicios
aleatorios qué quiere decir esto ninguno
va a tener las mismas preguntas no o
bien si queremos que todos a que esté
uniformado y que todos trabajen con el
mismo conjunto de preguntas
seleccionamos esta parte en este caso yo
voy a pedir que están aleatorios y aquí
también me dice que a qué clase quieres
asignárselo y yo aquí sí estoy dando
primero a primero de secundaria de 1º
secundaria si yo puedo seleccionar aquí
todas mis clases todos mis primeros de
secundaria para no tenerlo que hacerlo
de manera individual en cada clase pues
aquí estoy ahorrando como docente en
mucho tiempo imaginen si puedo asignar
mis tres recursos en un solo clic a mis
diferentes clases de primero de
secundaria o el tercero secundaria lo
que hacer y también aquí
puedo yo esta es una herramienta también
maravilloso porque aquí yo puedo
diferenciar vamos a suponer que esta es
la primera unidad del inicio a clases
del regreso a clases y solamente son
algunos alumnos los que realmente
necesitan repasar esta información
entonces yo lo voy a seleccionar a todos
yo solamente voy a asignarlo a aquellos
alumnos que yo considero que necesitan
repasar esta información para poder
seguir adelante no entonces aquí es
donde maestros nos facilitan la vida
muchísimo porque podemos personalizar el
aprendizaje diferencia de nuestro salón
de clases a través de un clic pero como
un campeonato me están pidiendo que los
tres recursos se asignen a todos mis
alumnos entonces yo voy a hacer
seleccionar la parte de a todos no
seleccionar y asignar esta estos
recursos a todos mis alumnos aquí voy a
poner la fecha límite recuerden que son
tres mínimo por semana entonces si mi
última clave
no la semana los veo los viernes así que
para el viernes 17 incluso puedo cambiar
la hora si mi clase es a las 11 de la
mañana les voy a decir ok
quiero que está estos recursos estén
completados para esta fecha ya esta hora
y automáticamente le hago clic en quién
asignar y la tarea que da asignar a los
alumnos van a recibir un correo pero
además también en su página de alumnos
van a recibir esta tarea ahora puede
darse el caso no en que yo estoy
planeando por ejemplo ahorita mis clases
de la semana que entra
dentro de dos semanas no a la mejor mis
clases del mes entonces yo puedo también
asignar contenido actividad acz
perdón asignar mis recursos pero
guardarlos en lugar de asignar los de
inmediato no entonces por ejemplo si yo
me voy a un tema más adelante no estoy
viendo yo vamos a ver que empiezo ya con
el tema de factores y múltiplos entonces
si yo estoy planeando no está estas
clases que voy a dar a futuro puedo
decir ok vamos a ver que quiero
a signar vamos a ver este nuevamente
estos ejercicios no las fracciones en la
recta numérica nuevamente puedo ver no
de qué se tratan estos ejercicios si
estoy de acuerdo lo seleccionó y puedo
también asignar fracciones unitarias y
puedo también asignar un cuestionario no
también para los alumnos de con cinco
preguntas una especie especie de
evaluación y yo aquí puedo asignar
nuevamente pero aquí va aquí lo voy a
hacer diferente
nuevamente puedo ser cambiar esto según
mis necesidades o lo que yo desee hacer
asignar las diferentes clases nuevamente
asignarlo a todos mis estudiantes o
algunos en particular poner mi fecha la
hora pero aquí en lugar de hacer clic en
el botón de asignar voy a hacer clic en
el botón de guardar y asignar más tarde
entonces hago clic aquí y
automáticamente en mis recursos quedan
guardados dentro de la plataforma para
que cuando yo ya esté lista y yo ya ya
esté cubriendo esta unidad
de sus temas ya pueda asignar no
entonces puedo ir adelantando y
planeando mis clases con antelación y
guardando los recursos que planeo
asignar en cada semana no ahora una vez
que regreso yo aquí a mi página
principal si yo me voy a tareas que esto
es una parte nueva totalmente nueva para
aquellos que ya han utilizado kahn
academia antes se van a sorprender con
esta parte porque realmente es una una
manera muy nueva y una manera muy
novedosa en que khan academy nos está
presentando esta página de tareas y
hambre espectacular porque me permite
realmente ver no el desempeño de cada
uno de mis alumnos en sus diferentes
tareas o sea sin tener que hacer clic en
el alumno ni nada a que automáticamente
tengo acceso a todas sus calificaciones
sus tareas etcétera no de todos los
alumnos que están inscritos en mi clase
todos aquí ya puedo ver no aquí ya tengo
las fracciones en la recta numérica aquí
ya tengo
cuáles son las tareas que acabo de
asignar entonces si le hago clic esto es
por alumno por alumno me permite ver su
desempeño en cada tarea vamos a suponer
que yo quiero ver aquí este no vamos a
ver este de acá lourdes de la cueva se
sacó 75 en esta tarea yo hago clic en él
en la calificación y me abre el reporte
entonces aquí que les puede ser a mí me
encanta esta parte porque aquí estamos
recibiendo información en tiempo real
los alumnos están en casa contestando la
tarea y nosotros en casa recibiendo sus
respuestas ya no tenemos que esperar a
llegar al siguiente día que me entreguen
las tareas me las llevo a casa las
calificó y tres días después si bien nos
va así no a veces pasa hasta unas
semanas les estoy dando
retroalimentación aquí es inmediato aquí
automáticamente yo hablo y va a ver qué
pasó con esta niña que está con 75 y
aquí puedo ver que tuvo dos problemas en
los que sacó cero o hasta tres en los
demás los contestó puede
bien entonces qué voy a hacer yo con
esta información el siguiente día de
clases no cuando la vuelva a ver voy a
hacer a lo mejor un grupo ya todos esos
alumnos que tuvieron más de 86 % que
sacar un 100 por ciento les voy a dar
una actividad a la mejor que sea lo que
no sé que requiera de más esfuerzo que
de más pensamiento crítico en la
actividad más significativa sin embargo
voy a jalar a todos estos son los que
tuvieron 70 o menos 70 por ciento o
menos en su tarea y voy a enseñarles el
concepto o vamos a repasar los
ejercicios que tuvieron mano entonces
esto es en tiempo real
automáticamente yo sé cómo está haciendo
el desempeño de mi alumno
automáticamente en un clic no entonces
aquí veo que está alumno tiene saco al
cien por cien todo no tiene ningún
problema para qué le voy a volver a
mandar la misma tarea cuando ya haya
clase
yo ya sé qué voy a hacer con este alumno
o le voy a dar le voy a pedir que siga
practicando en khan academy este mismo
concepto porque le va a ir dando el
material un poco más difícil o voy a
tener para él otra actividad
yo diseñada para este tipo de alumnos no
y como les digo me enfocaré en clase en
aquellos alumnos que están teniendo
dificultades en entender el concepto
entonces este es el valor enorme que
tiene estos reportes y bueno si yo hago
clic aquí en por tarea
aquí automáticamente me dice que cuáles
son tus tareas que has asignado
cuando las asignadas t cuál es la fecha
de entrega y la hora quienes las han
completado no aquí tengo dos de 19
etcétera y también si hago clic en
guardada me va a decir cuáles son las
tareas que yo he creado y he guardado
para asignar después y es bien sencillo
una vez que ya estoy lista que ya llegué
a este tema a esta unidad digo ok ya
estoy lista para asignar este recurso
voy a asignar mis tres recursos y les
hago clic en asignar sí y
automáticamente
van a aparecer en mis tareas guardadas
nosotros ya de allí ya de entrada entran
a aparecer en las tareas perdón activas
y ya los alumnos van a recibir el correo
y van a recibir estas tareas en su
página de alumnos preguntas hasta aquí y
christina
siento que todo está bien hay más nada
más nadie
cuántos intentos tienen los alumnos en
cada tarea los alumnos tienen hasta
cuatro pistas a las que pueden recurrir
en ocasiones son tres en ocasiones son
cuatro pero para acceder al vídeo y
pueden tener diferentes pistas no hoy
este y tienen hasta tres o cuatro pistas
e intentos para que puedan resolver
problemas generalmente a la primera o la
segunda el alumno entiende y el alumno
es capaz de contestar no pero si tiene
diferentes oportunidades y a veces lo
que es bueno lo que sucede cuando los
alumnos no contestan bien una pregunta
de siete la plataforma les agrega una
más no les agrega más preguntas para que
puedan tener más oportunidades de
contestar con éxito cuando un alumno
saca de 70% en adelante se considera
como ya ha practicado si sacan menos se
considera como que el alumno no ha
practicado o que está teniendo problemas
con el concepto entonces siempre como
docentes como les digo nos corresponde
motivarlos no que no se conformen con un
70% no esté sigue
practicando hasta que logres el 80 hasta
que regrese el 90 hasta que llegues al
100% de porcentaje en ese concepto
un recurso es una serie de ejercicios un
vídeo un recurso es un vídeo una serie
de ejercicios un artículo los ejercicios
y siempre vienen en grupos de siete en
su mayoría no habrá a veces grupos de
cinco si es una evaluación etcétera pero
en general son grupos de siete
ejercicios entonces un recurso es eso un
vídeo un artículo o un grupo de
ejercicios
leonel villa considero que esto nos
facilitará nuestra tarea como docentes
que te puedo decir totalmente de acuerdo
contigo de verdad que este una vez que
empezamos a utilizar esta plataforma de
verdad de verdad podemos tener este un
poco más de tiempo para nosotros porque
si nos permite y además es un
satisfactorio no porque además de
permitirnos no tener un poco más de
tiempo para planear para realmente hacer
lo que nos gusta además de enseñar
también nos permite abordar con más
éxito las necesidades de nuestros
jóvenes todo eso es esta parte es muy
importante
y geo está súper el cambio para el
manejo de las tareas es mucho más
sencillo totalmente de acuerdo contigo
me encantó cuando vi este cambio ya es
mucho más visual es mucho más fácil de
acceder es infinitamente más sencillo no
también a mí me encantó este cambio es
muy nuevo apenas lo estamos estrenando
así que brabo por khan academy que nos
sigue facilitando el trabajo y bueno
vamos a ver ahora
estas nuevas características de la
plataforma y como fomentamos la
mentalidad de crecimiento voy a entrar
nuevamente para esto a la plataforma
déjenme cierro todo esto
ok entonces voy a entrar a la plataforma
y aquí en la plataforma tengo otra vez
algo nuevo que se hizo khan academy o en
lo que trabajaron es en la parte del
avance no esta parte también hicieron
grandes cambios y me encantó cómo quedó
está súper claro
no sé muy efectivo para mi la salud
visual y bueno la información es más que
clara aquí y además aquí tienes lo que
cada academy está haciendo aquí cada
cambio que están siendo ok el alumno
puede tener un avance dentro de lo que
es la materia ósea en general el curso
de pre álgebra pero también le va a
indicar el avance del alumno en cada una
de las unidades de este curso entonces
si yo me voy aquí avance aquí están
todos los estudiantes que pueden ser
esconderlos y al hacer clic los oculta
estudiantes y al hacer clic ok me dice
que 30 estudiantes han cubierto entre 0
y 10 y 19 por ciento de el curso de pre
algebra no entonces nuestro estudiantes
y si yo lo veo aquí pues si no éste es
una clase muy nueva apenas estoy
comenzando pues si la mayoría de mis
alumnos se fijan aquí al lado del alumno
hay un porcentaje ese me indica qué
porcentaje del curso ha cubierto ese
alumno entonces aquí por ejemplo tengo
lourdes ha cubierto el 1
denis ha cubierto el 2% julio ernesto ha
cubierto el 5% nos a lo cual pues apenas
estamos iniciando esto esperamos en las
primeras semanas de clases entonces y
aquí me va a ir indicando fíjense qué
interesante aquí me dice que para yo
poder cubrir el 100% de los conceptos
que debo enseñar entre álgebra necesito
un total de 25 mil 750 puntos eso
correspondería al cien por ciento del
curso de pre al gp entonces los alumnos
a medida que van practicando y a medida
que van avanzando y ganando puntos
etcétera
ellos van subiendo en porcentaje y van
ganando puntos cuál es el objetivo del
alumno y cuál es el objetivo de nosotros
como docentes que los alumnos a final de
año hayan cumplido con 25 me lo hayan
ganado 25 mil 750 puntos para haber
cubierto el 100% del curso de pre
álgebra
entonces aquí a lo largo del año vamos
ir viendo
como esta barra se va moviendo a 20 a 20
por ciento a 40 a 60 y tendremos alumnos
pues distribuidos en los diferentes
niveles el objetivo es que todos a final
de año terminen aquí en el 100% también
si yo me voy hacia abajo aquí me dice el
desempeño de mis alumnos por unidades
entonces eso es todavía más padre no
porque aquí me dice aquí yo puedo
detectar alumnos que a lo mejor en la
unidad 1 guau estuvieron magníficos y
lograron el 100 por ciento también y
estuvieron estupendos pero también o sea
por ejemplo hay estas propiedades
aritméticas no si yo hago clic aquí me
dice que para poder alcanzar el 100 por
ciento en propiedades aritméticas
necesitan haber ganado 1200 puntos
entonces puede ser yo aquí voy a ver
también aquí está el una ya lleva el 8
etcétera la idea es que
consiguen 1200 puntos como lo consiguen
practicando practicando para que vayan
pasando en los diferentes niveles que
vienen siendo de no empezar a practicar
a que esta familiar
competente hasta que lleguen a dominados
una vez que lleguen a dominados alcanzan
el 100% no entonces
aquí en
entonces en este avance por unidad yo
puedo ir viendo cómo van cómo va
haciendo el desempeño de mis alumnos por
unidad no por unidad entonces puede ser
porque los pasar que un alumno en la
unidad uno le fue estupendo en la unidad
2 estupendo pero en la unidad 3 se está
empezando a tener problemas y para la
unidad 5 ya lo perdimos no el niño ya
está re probando etcétera entonces esta
manera en que nos están presentando el
avance me permite detectar desde un
principio a un alumno que empieza a
tener dificultades desde un principio
porque no podemos pretender que un
alumno que tiene problemas con
fracciones tenga éxito en resolver
ecuaciones con fracciones no entonces
desde aquí yo puedo detectar si el
alumno no pasa del 40 por ciento aquí yo
sé que tengo que sentarme con el alumno
y ayudarlo no o enseñarles concepto o
que practique más mandarle artículos
etcétera de manera que pueda reforzar
ese concepto o esa unidad para pasarla
con éxito no entonces esto de verdad es
información invaluable o sea me encanta
la manera en que lo están presentando y
también tenemos la parte de actividad
que esta parte de actividad me permite
definir no y me permite ver cuál es la
actividad de cada uno de mis alumnos
dentro de la plataforma no entonces si
yo les estoy pidiendo que de tarea
practiquen media hora en can academy yo
aquí voy a saber quién es quién sí quién
o qué habilidades practicaron qué vídeos
vieron si fue durante las horas de
escuela si fue fuera de las horas de
escuela todos también me da información
muy valiosa no de cada uno
de mis saludos
entonces esto es básicamente lo nuevo la
plataforma básicamente los cambios están
en tareas y en avance pero como ven
bueno este realmente estos cambios nos
van a permitir trabajar de una manera
mucho más eficiente y ahorrar también
tiempo no facilitándonos mucho el poder
detectar cuál es el desempeño de
nuestros alumnos en cada momento del año
escolar
y regresamos a la presentación alguna
pregunta
hay algunos temas que no permiten
asignar todos los temas que están en
khan academy se permite asignar usar
todo el contenido que está dentro de el
curso que tú selecciones en can academy
y todo este contenido se va a poder
asignar si acaso cuando encuentran un
tema no que no esté disponible pueden
escribir un correo a khan academy y
obviamente no lo pueden asignar porque
no está el contenido pero en su mayoría
la mayoría de los de los conceptos están
dentro de los contenidos y puedes
asignar cualquier recurso de los
contenidos que tienes
ok
recuerden que muchos de estos para
asignar también son por ejemplo de un
artículo o de un vídeo yo no puedo tener
una calificación no se puede
yo voy a
asignarlo pero no voy a recibir un
reporte de eso no solamente saber que lo
vieron pero ni siquiera hacer porque el
pueden abrir y no verlo no realmente de
lo único que yo estoy segura es cuando
hace un ejercicio es porque de ahí voy a
recibir una calificación de ese recurso
ok cuál es que es la mentalidad de
crecimiento entonces como yo les
comentaba esta esta nueva modalidad este
nuevo concepto de mentalidad de
crecimiento está planeado para que
nuestros alumnos desarrollen una
mentalidad de aprendizaje
estas actividades se enfocan en
actividades que van a beneficiar el
desarrollo intelectual de nuestros
alumnos no que nuestros alumnos puedan
conocer cuál es su proceso de
aprendizaje se hagan responsables de su
propio aprendizaje y todas estas
actividades fueron desarrolladas por
verts que es un centro de estudios de
stanford a partir de las investigaciones
de la doctora carol dweck y éstas bueno
esto cubre diferentes factores nuestras
mentalidades estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento están
diseñadas no para que el alumno pueda
desarrollar
y residencia para que pueda superar la
frustración superar digamos el fracaso
no sin querer ser sin tener que quedarse
atorados en este fracaso no poder este
superar la angustia no puede no tener
éxito de no entender de sentirse atrás
de sus compañeros etcétera y les cambia
el chip en la cabeza no de que de que
muchos de ellos piensan que al tener al
tener errores no están fracasando o no y
es cambiarles el chip de que los errores
son oportunidades de crecimiento
oportunidades de aprendizaje y esto es
importante que lo entiendan para la vida
no solamente en matemáticas entonces
también en esta herramienta fomentamos
no actividades para que puedan
desarrollar estrategias para superar la
frustración estrategias que les permita
aprender de una mejor manera para crear
mentes
y que sean fuertes no mentes orientadas
al éxito eso es el objetivo de este tipo
de actividades no son realmente
actividades que no tienen nada que ver
con matemáticas ni con ciencias etcétera
son actividades muy diversas en donde
ellos van a crear metas y a mentalizarse
para tener éxito no enfrentarse al
inesperado este tipo de actividades
solamente se dan en bachillerato y para
desarrollar también un sentido de
pertenencia y estas actividades también
son orientadas a bachillerato entonces
algunas áreas en las que una mentalidad
de crecimiento ayuda a comenzar el año
escolar con el pie derecho es bueno los
alumnos van a tener algunos casos de
estudios de casos vídeos testimoniales
lo que van a aprender a través de
experiencias de otros lo que eso también
es muy importante para que más adelante
ellos puedan también reflexionar sobre
sus propias experiencias y su propio
aprendizaje lecciones muy apropiadas a
la edad
dependiendo se están en primaria en
secundaria en bachillerato y van a
recibir diferentes recursos guías
etcétera vídeos también para que ustedes
puedan ir implementando estas
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
esto es un requisito también dentro del
campeonato junto con los tres recursos
que ustedes van a asignar cada semana
también van a deberán ir asignando estas
actividades de mentalidad de
aprendizajes y les van dando información
a medida que avance el campeonato pero
es también un requisito asignar estas
actividades y que los alumnos las
complete en
ok llegamos a esta parte de los módulos
como les comentamos en un principio el
objetivo de estos tres módulos es
capacitarlos de manera que ustedes al
final de esta capacitación de cada uno
de los módulos reciban un reconocimiento
por su esfuerzo también por su tiempo no
por su participación en estos módulos
entonces que requieren hacer que
necesitan hacer para obtener sus
reconocimientos entonces la tarea del
módulo 1 el módulo 1 ya tuvo lugar como
les les decía aquí si ustedes no
participaron en este webinar del primero
de agosto les dejamos aquí el enlace de
youtube y puedan nada más copiar
[Música]
y tienen ahí
por favor en este momento no deben hacer
clic en este formulario que dice debes
registrarte usando este formulario al
hacer clic aquí automáticamente se va a
abrir el formulario este es el
formulario que tienen que completar si
ya lo completaron no tienen que
completarlo otra vez solamente se
necesita una vez entonces aquí viene los
diferentes horarios las diferentes ligas
de los módulos que vamos a tener les
pedimos su nombre completo les pedimos
su correo ojo utilicen el correo que
pongan aquí el correo con el que
abrieron su cuenta de khan academy aquí
completan esta información y lo envían
así de sencillo
ok
otra tarea de esta parte de este módulo
es a crear una clase bueno antes que
nada sin nada si no tienen todavía su
cuenta en khan academy obvio el primer
paso es abrir su cuenta en khan academy
si es que no lo hicieron conmigo ahorita
y van a crear una clase puede ser una
clase de modo una clase de prueba
pónganle clase prueba inicio de cursos
lo que ustedes quieran invitan a un
colega le invitan a su hermana inviten a
su hijo invitan a alguien de la familia
lo único aquí es que ustedes agarren
confianza y sepan cómo van a crear ya
sus clases cuando entren a la escuela y
asignen contenido así tengan un alumno y
sea su esposa su hijo su vecino su prima
etcétera así en el contenido del curso
que les hayan asignado asignen 3 con 3
recursos y
y pedirle a la persona que complete la
tarea asignada o completando ustedes
mismos yo muchas veces lo que hago me
invitó a mí misma me invitó a mí misma
como alumna y me contestó yo mi misma
tarea no entonces lo pueden hacer
invitarse a ustedes mismos como alumnos
y contestar y verlo así tiene la
posibilidad de ver y de percibir como
sus alumnos
entonces cree en su clase inviten a su
alumno inviten sí a sí mismos asignen
tres recursos complete en la tarea
asignada y otra parte de la tarea y aquí
es muy importante esta tarea es vital
para que puedan recibir su
reconocimiento del módulo aquí les voy a
pedir que creen un plan y lo compartan
en este formulario de que va a ser este
plan
aquí objetivo es que ustedes comiencen a
pensar en ideas de cómo van a motivar a
sus alumnos cómo van a reconocer sus
logros no entonces si semana acá abajo
aquí igual les pedimos información
básica y aquí
no les voy a pedir que propongan tres
ideas para motivar a sus alumnos durante
el campeonato que qué idea se les ocurra
en crear un plan para reconocer los
esfuerzos de tus alumnos cómo piensan
reconocer el logro de sus estudiantes
con toda esta información nosotros vamos
a dar entrenamiento
y podemos enriquecer mucho todo esto de
esta experiencia
la tarea del módulo 2 que es este módulo
si no se han registrado nuevamente les
pedimos que lo hagan ahora en este
formulario nuevamente con que hagan clic
aquí los va a llevar al formulario a
atender al menos a una sesión de
seguimiento ahora una vez que ya tengan
creada sus clases y que ya hayan
recuerden hayan eliminado sus clases
viejas y creados sus clases nuevas les
vamos a pedir que se inscriban en
campeonato nos recuerden que para crear
para inscribir sus clases tienen que
tener un mínimo de 10 alumnos en cada
clase
ok entonces este viene siendo la tarea
del módulo 2 inscribirse ya en
campeonato
entonces los siguientes pasos es si no
se han registrado recuerden que tienen
que registrarse porque les pedimos esto
de manera tan insistente porque de esta
manera van a poder recibir información
del programa además de el reconocimiento
para su esfuerzo entonces sí es muy
importante que la completan y también en
este documento que les ponemos que ahí
está la liga vamos a estar añadiendo
información a este documento durante los
próximos seis meses toda la información
referente a este programa de
capacitación va a estar en aumento
entonces vamos a estar actualizando
constantemente ábralo guárdelo etcétera
pónganlo en su pongan león este bucal
con lo que sea de manera que puedan
acceder a ellos fácilmente y recuerden
en cumplir con las tareas del módulo 1
para recibir su primer reconocimiento y
las tareas del módulo 2 para antes del
primero de octubre para recibir
su segundo reconocimiento
y pues por mi parte es todo les
agradezco de verdad su participación su
tiempo su compromiso la verdad es que la
labor de ustedes es muy importante no en
méxico todos estamos conscientes de el
gran cambio que necesitan la educación
de nuestra paz en nuestro país y del
gran esfuerzo que estamos haciendo todos
por lograr este cambio y la verdad es
que esta plataforma pone muchos recursos
y realmente nos da la herramienta y no
se nos ofrece una herramienta de manera
que podamos lograr este cambio no de
manera que podamos hacer este cambio más
fácil tanto para los alumnos como para
nosotros entonces quedó que damos a sus
órdenes aquí en esta diapositiva les
dejo un correo que es o la arroba khan
academy punto org les regles recuerdo
que en este correo pueden enviarnos sus
sugerencias preguntas dudas comentarios
pero sobre todo sus experiencias no sé
es de verdad muy importante y sería
increíble recibir sus vídeos así como
tenemos de brasil y de estados
nos encantaría tener de méxico no es
celebrando el éxito celebrando el logro
y recuerden también que si entran a ese
punto cero punto khan academy punto org
los alumnos si entran desde su celular
pueden hacer uso de la plataforma sin
tener que usar sus datos
muchísimas gracias y quedamos a sus
órdenes en este correo para cualquier
pregunta o comentario christine
muchísimas gracias
y en suerte la próxima semana
con tus alumnos y estamos en contacto
gracias gracias hasta luego